Bill Murray once kissed you once you
were in the audience how'd you know that
somebody said that or you found it
unbelievable what what that here's what
was funny about that is so some fans
said oh yeah on Twitter or something
yeah Bill Murray and I went you know
what I never was kissed by Bill Murray
on Saturday Night Live and they say yeah
yeah you were in the audience I said no
no I wasn't they showed me the video
and I couldn't even recognize myself
except for one thing I knit the sweater
I was wearing and I remembered the
sweater because it took me a long time
to knit it and I kept it for decades I
wore that thing out and I went it's got
to be me because that is my sweater I
mean that was like this very striped
weird thing was it a big kiss oh he went
right in yeah oh yeah no no he did you
didn't know him he just went up to you
well no what happened was because I
first of all it all is it's kind of come
back to me vaguely there was somebody in
New York who was
worked on Saturday Night Live who was a
friend of mine and she said we've got to
go I've got his seats let's do it and I
thought well that'd be fun sure I'd love
to and I do remember now that it was
very specific that we were sitting right
in the front row so I think she knew
that this was going to happen I had no
idea it was going to happen so he jumped
off the stage yeah and he plays a big
old kiss he wouldn't be able to do it
now because yeah no but um were you kind
of like well
I was like Bill give me a phone number
we'll I'll call you I'm surprised he
didn't call you or try to get in touch
with you why would he are you beautiful
uh-huh yeah he's a he's okay
what do you mean I mean back then I'm
surprised like now you hear all that
stuff with Bill Murray and you're like
well I know you know well whatever isn't
it something I hate you know you find
out about your Heroes and hey I was on
The Cosby Show and I'm thanking my stars
that his wife's best friend Carmen
delavalot or something was on the show
that episode too so his wife was around
and I'm like I'm glad that was happening
because who knows Jesus